Magnussen's businessman there's
something very proper about what he does
he he goes through a world that respects
and honors and accommodates him hey
youtubers it's Charlie and his last vow
just aired and left us with so many
questions so it's time to do another Q&A
the good news is is that they've already
plotted out series four they started
working on it and they kind of know
where series 5 is headed so there's
gonna be plenty more Sherlock just to
fill the Sherlock shaped hole that's in
all of our chests right now while we
wait for series 4 to get here I'm gonna
be doing Musketeers videos starting on
Sunday that's gonna be a Sunday show
just like Sherlock was like last time I
just picked 20 of your questions I
condensed some of the answers because a
lot of the questions were the same I'm
also holding a lot of the series 4 based
questions for my series for Q&A I'll be
doing a predictions video later this
week and then after that I'll do another
Q&A be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a lot of fun
careful for spoilers in this video
though because we will be talking about
specific plot points so if you haven't
seen his last value just wait to watch
this Q the mine palace so let's get
started question number 1 chaos now asks
where Jeannine and Sherlock just using
each other or did she believe Sherlock's
lies she sold their story to the
tabloids and made a bunch of money so I
think she didn't know Sherlock was lying
to her I think she was surprised she
also disabled his morphine at his fight
so she was really pissed at him so no I
don't think she knew question number 2
Stephanie Vicente asks did Sherlock know
that Magnussen was cam from the wedding
telegraph before he learned Mary's
secret no he probably didn't realize the
connection between Mary and Magnussen
until he was in the hospital question
number 3 fangirl 1502 asks what is up
with everyone talking about the 3rd
Holmes brother
so Mycroft has this scene where he talks
about the other one and a lot of people
are either theorizing that it's either
red beard the dog or he's talking about
another Holmes brother that you know
died at some point in the past based on
what we know now I think he's just
talking about red beard of the dog but
if there is another Holmes brother I'm
hoping that it has something to do with
the series for plot question number 4 IV
hey asks could you rank all of your
favorite sherlock episodes so right now
let's say an order of you know most
favorite to least favorite its scandal
sign a three Reichenbach great game last
foul empty hearse study in pink
Baskerville and blind banker question
number five Lanza basilia asks do you
think that Moriarty is still alive
good question yes and no I'll say that
the person you saw shoot himself on the
rooftop during Reichenbach is definitely
dead but I'm saving a lot of the more we
already talked for my series four videos
question number six Philip ro Kovac asks
what was your funniest moment I would
have to say Sherlock and Mycroft getting
caught smoking during Christmas by their
mother that was really funny
question number seven brooke hester asks
did you think that the goodbye scene was
too cold honestly I think that Watson is
just you know getting on with his life
he's kind of made peace with Mary's past
so he's not mad about that anymore and
remember that the two of them are you
know very traditional British men so
they're not going to show a lot of
outward emotion that's why when they hug
you know during the wedding it was such
a huge deal because you know they don't
do that a lot
question number 8 Caroline gues asks how
do you think they'll bring Moriarty back
so I actually have a very detailed
theory about Moriarty and his appearance
and said scene I'll talk more about that
during my series 4 predictions video
though I'll say is is that there is
another Skywalker if you get my meaning
question number 9 Michael Merck asks
who's a better villain Moriarty or
Magnussen so I'll say that I liked
Andrew Scott's performances more already
better but you know as a real world like
if these were real world people
Magnussen would be a better villain just
because he's a better businessman
remember Mycroft said that he is under
his protection because he is useful to
the British government every once in a
while
question number 10 Blake Hutton asks do
you think that Sherlock being a murderer
got out or do you think that the
government covered it up I definitely
think that they covered it up remember
Mycroft said that England will always
need Sherlock Holmes but he is a
murderer so they basically sent him into
exile but putting him on this mission
for six months you know before the
events of those last few seconds kind of
changed circumstances question number 11
cam Edwards asks did you expect Sherlock
to do what he did at the end how else
could he have resolved the plot I was
very surprised by you know the
resolution of that main conflict the
only other way to stop him remember the
information only existed inside of
Magnussen so they would have had to you
know permanently incapacitate him which
would have been really hard without
killing him question number 12 sent up
34 asks do you think that we'll ever
learn what Augustus had on Mary no I
don't think that we're meant to that's
why they burn that hard drive Watson
says he doesn't care you know she's Mary
Watson to him
I think Sherlock knows but in reality
you know she was just an assassin so she
just killed a bunch of people question
number 13
Sara Mia asks how are Magnussen and
Maury already connected is one
controlling the other so based on these
circumstances in the situation's we know
from series one two three just based on
that information I would say that
neither is working for the other they're
just like fellow businessmen that trade
information Moriarty probably has
snipers on Magnussen at all times and
Magnussen probably has a lot of dirt on
Moriarty I'm hoping that something in
series four kind of changes that context
question number 14 olivia Bembe asks why
do you think that the people in
Sherlock's my palace during the middle
of the episode were there so you're
talking about Molly Mycroft and Moriarty
three M's that's funny the mine palace
conjures up the most relevant people to
help solve a problem and obviously
Sherlock is fighting for his life so
Molly is the best medical professional
that he knows so she's the first person
to kind of give him the medical
information Mycroft is the most rational
person he knows so he can helps to make
the decision about putting the pieces
together about his environment and then
Moriarty basically helps them deal with
the pain question number 15 Chelsea Park
and asks why did Magnussen mention
Mary's family in the letter at her
wedding
he probably just been blackmailing Mary
for a long time so he was just
with her like whenever he was flicking
Watson's eye question number 16 X bloody
desires X asks what did you think about
Sherlock becoming a murderer now I
actually think that it's totally in
keeping with the character remember he's
a high-functioning sociopath so he's
gonna solve a problem the best way he
knows how
and obviously in this case it was you
know erasing the you know harddrive so
to speak with a bullet question number
17 hombre Truong Nez asks could you
explain the 221b door that flashed
during Sherlock's big mind palace
sequence 221 Baker Street is just a
visual representation of what his life
is and he was basically just trying to
claw his way back to life question
number 18 ether asks does Sherlock use
patches to cover up his habit Jeanine
had a right hand ring as do the clown
gang members did the Rings mean the same
thing I definitely always imagined
Sherlock with patches all over his body
all the time but I think what you're
implying is is that you know was he
using patches to cover up a heroin habit
I don't think so I think he was using
during this episode you know as part of
that case but I don't think he you know
completely fallen off the deep end and
the
this is actually really interesting
that's a good question there are a lot
of people in the series you know
including Mycroft and Thea now Jeanine
that have right-hand rings especially
the clown gang members I'm hoping that
something in series four kind of goes to
explain that or something manifests that
kind of connects them all because that
would be really really awesome question
number 19
Vica attribute asks is Sherlock not a
virgin anymore so even though he was in
that drug den for that whole month it's
kind of implied that he was going back
every night to 221b Baker Street to be
with Jeanine so I definitely think that
they were having sex the real question
is is was he high when they were doing
it and question 20 last one mega fluffs
asks what Sherlock I at the beginning of
the episode the episode does imply that
he was high whenever Molly slapped him
but I don't think that he was you know
ritualistically using throughout the
series I think it was just during this
episode during that one month period
thank you so much for submitting your
questions guys this was a lot of fun I'm
saving a lot of those post credits
questions for my series for QA donor
I'll be doing a predictions video
tomorrow and then the day after that
I'll do a Q&A you know just for series
for questions
also remember Musketeers videos starting
this Sunday I'm really excited it's
gonna be a lot of fun right now click
here to get my review of episode 3 and
click here to get my review for episode
2 thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tomorrow high fives
you